the soul of new orleans since 2006 has
been drew brees yeah mickey loomis the
gm of the team addressed yesterday the
future of a quarterback who is now 41
and it appears the saints have some
tough decisions to make at the position
here's what loomis had to say about
brees potentially being a saint in 2020
drew brees be a part of this franchise
moving forward
um
you have to ask drew that i
think you want to keep running backwards
uh yeah obviously
is that market one that's
kind of interesting to try to figure out
what it is exactly right yeah i i don't
know that i want to make any comments
about that um
you know i think the first thing is
you know it's clear we'd love to have
drew back and if he wants to be back
then we'll go from there so
i mean i'm assuming that he does
yeah i mean that's only part of it what
they offer him financially will reflect
how much they value him i mean maybe
they look at it and say
drew we want you back but we want to use
taysom hill more next year because we
all recognize how much more potent he
can be as a change of pace guy we're not
ready to make him the quarterback we
want you to be the quarterback and so
it's almost like not not co-starters but
maybe we're going to use taysom hill 12
to 25 percent of the time so we're going
to pay you less so we can pay him more
and keep it all together he's going to
have to be willing to do that especially
if there's somebody else out there and i
don't know that there is two years ago
right when he was due to become a free
agent chris remember i was banging the
vikings should sign him drum i don't
think anybody's going to be lining up to
sign drew brees now so if he does want
to keep playing it's going to be at the
offer that the saints put on the table
and that offer may be reduced in
recognition of the fact that they also
have to find a way to keep take some
hell around yeah the taste of hill
factor is real in this whole situation
too i mean taysom hill i mean i'm sure
he's gonna want his agent to test the
market can kind of get a feel for
what he would get if he became a free
agent that way and could go out there
and make money we know that sean payton
loves them that way
i'm not surprised to hear mickey loomis
say this and all that you know drew
brees had a real good year there's no
doubt about it you know the problem is
at some point they got to learn they got
to figure out when to cut the court you
know one thing is you can't look at the
stats when it comes to drew brees i'm
just it doesn't matter you know the
stats are going to be good next year
even if he's not one of the five or one
of the 10 best quarterbacks of football
you know again i would say he wasn't one
of the 10 best quarterbacks in football
this year but his stats will tell you
that it doesn't matter who plays
quarterback in new orleans the stats are
going to be good you know teddy
bridgewater stats were pretty good and
he didn't lose a football game as a
starter there you know so it's not i'm
not trying to disrespect drew brees but
i know i am to a degree but that's just
where he is in his age at this point so
that's where i find it interesting and
yes the taste of hill thing he you know
has continued to become a better passer
and how many games this year mike did we
come away going hey taysom hill was the
best player on the saints offense he was
the best player on the field in general
you know how long are you going to roll
this dice and and maybe anger him to
where he doesn't feel like he's getting
to play uh as much as he wants either so
that's where i think this whole thing is
uh interesting and fascinating
and i don't want to make too much of
this angle but
taysom hill is gonna be making the
rounds at radio row next week he's one
of the guests that tells you the program
and and it tells me he's ready exactly
ready
to cash in on his ability and maybe to
expand his role with the saints or
someone else and look mechanically
here's how it works he's a restricted
free agent the saints can apply the
highest possible tender it would pay him
six million dollars
and there would be an opportunity for
another team to sign into an offer sheet
that if the saints can't or won't match
it they would get a first round pick as
compensation and and look if they paid
drew brees 20 to 25 million and they got
another 20 million plus in dead money
from breeze pass contracts they have to
figure out how to deal with there's a
chance they can't afford hill and
somebody else makes an offer that the
saints look at and say we just can't
match this
they they need to get him signed weeks
before it gets to that point i think so
well i mean taysom hill i think is
taking a risk and all that anyways i
don't know if i'd be happy with any of
that you know oh wait oh great i get to
come back this year at six million
dollars when listen we know that's a lot
of money in the real world and all that
but this is football and there's a
different price tag as far as you know
who deserves what and what the inventory
on the shelf really costs all right i
mean taysom hill yeah six million
dollars but he's also going to go man i
think there's some teams out there that
would offer me more than that per year
and have a chance to play oh wait great
i get to go back to new orleans at 6
million a year and they can smash me
between the line of scrimmage and beat
me up to where now i'm a free agent the
next year and i'm not worth the same you
know those are things that taysom hill's
got to evaluate too you know it's not
necessarily fair to him that way too hey
taste them we don't want you to throw
the ball and do all that but we do love
when you just smash it up there and we
let nine guys crush you when you run the
ball can you do that for us again and
help us go to a super bowl run and then
when you're banged up and messed up hey
you can become a free agent and maybe
you'll become our quarterback maybe
somebody else's you know that's not an
easy thing to swallow for taysom hill
too so i expect drew brees to be back uh
but i do think that this will be his
last year i guess that's what i would
say uh to this whole situation
here's another thing to remember too
even though taysom hill isn't quite at
the marissa tome my biological clock is
ticking like this phase he's going to be
30 in august that's what i'm saying this
guy isn't 24 or 25. the window is only
open for so long and it may be it may be
his agent tells him we're not going to
take any offers from the saints i don't
care what they are we're going to make
them apply that rfa tag and we're going
to see what else may be out there and
the thing is and folks this is the open
secret in the nfl the tampering's
already happening if somebody wants to
taste some hill they're making it known
to taysom hill's agent hey
i wouldn't sign
whatever mickey loomis has on the table
at some creative thing where it's a code
job with we're ready to make you our guy
and we're ready to pay you accordingly
and we're ready to give up a first round
pick to make it happen yeah so they
don't know you're right the thing is i
don't know if he's played enough to have
anybody willing to give them that money
and really make that offer you know
that's where the sean payton and the
saints have a little bit of the power
all i know is this
he was the best guy on the field for
either team in the saints vikings
playoff game and that should mean
something maybe for the team that got
run roughshod rough shop rough shot over
by taysom hill who has a quarterback
under contract for only one more year
and maybe thinking our future isn't this
immobile statue
sorry kirk we'll see you next week in
the pocket it's a guy who can actually
move with the football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports